[Music]  some kids like cars expensive clothes  selfies money I found out I enjoy food  [Music]  he is a Muslim because of his father I'm  sorry is atheism matrilineal or petrol  in my name is Abraham sunomono J some  people call me Abraham some people call  me Abraham I prefer Abe  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  I wish I could cook something  communal that brings people together  what you do I was wondering if you could  teach me I gave you some help I want to  do the permits I can I can do both  things the big mess  [Music]  alcohol dovey intellect haven't you  noticed that in your father a Remington  it's a taco with ramen noodles terrible  you are mixing fusion week confusion  falling falafel the national food is  another way  al appropriate our culture is it was a  mistake bringing a child into your messy  [Music]  understands what I'm going through  [Music]  maybe your generation can find some kind  of peace  [Music]  you can't choose your family kid  you